we hope you're happy here oh shukran
thank you so much the kitty is still
hard to shoot yeah different language
different culture
everything but we knew inside this
country a long time come by by yourself
vegetable and do everything
yeah like yeah she takes some time but
no it's okay no stronger than me
my sister-in-law Fatma she is from China
and she's adjusted so much better than I
have
she covers her body she wears a heat Gap
and she lives like an Egyptian I've
always been curious as to how she's been
able to do that so easily
mom I come to Egypt I don't speak Arabic
try to learn Arabic fast I'm trying I
think every time I come it gets a little
bit no more words now
have you been able to like make friends
since you've been here no I just family
in the U.S we always just go out and
like meet meet people and they like sort
of become our family so that's why I was
asking
too much
it's just no family but big family no no
need outside friend
yes you have America too much foreign
I personally would like to make friends
here it's really important to me
and I'm worried because it's clear to me
that all of my problems when I left
Egypt the first time things like my
clothes and the noise and Chaos of
living with his family
they haven't gone anywhere they've
waited for me in Egypt I'm here until
were they
why would I think I'm getting all pretty
tired okay honey we can go through this
now it's a long day for here it's okay
you can have this I don't think I can
feel at home here without immediately
starting to address some of our issues
because if we just continue to pretend
that we're just happy sitting there with
a family drinking tea nothing ever
changes nice to see everybody I want to
see you again welcome back to Egypt
foreign